Let's say I go to the store today and there
have a sale to Guava
Everything is 30% cheaper
This applies to Guava
And only today
Only today
And I say to you, you know what, I'll take a little guava
So I buy 6 guavas
I buy 6 guavas.
And it ends up, when I go to the register, and we're
assuming no tax, it's a grocery and I live in a state where
they do not tax groceries.
So for the six guavas I bought, I get a 30% discount
I charge 12 BGN and 60 BGN
$ 12.60.
This is the discount price for 6 guavas
I'm going home, and my girlfriend tells me, you know, Iane,
Will you get two more guavas tomorrow?
I say, of course.
So the next day I go and want to buy 2 more fruits
2 guava 22 00: 01: 00,003 -> 00: 01: 01,075 But the sale has passed
No more discount 30%
It was only the first day I bought the six
So how much will these 2 guavas cost me?
How much is the real price of these guavas?
The whole price
A good start would be to think about how much
They would cost those 6 guavas without the reduction
That's the price here
This is the price
How much would they cost me without the reduction?
Let's find out with some algebra
Let's choose the right color for algebra
Maybe this gray color
Let's say x is the price of 6 guavas
six guavas without a reduction.
In fact, if we take 30% of that
we need to get 12.60. .
Let's do that
So if we have the whole price of 6 guavas, we will
we take 30% of it
This is the same as 0.30.
or I can just write 0.3.
I could ignore zero if I want to.
Actually, let's write it like that
My girlfriend always makes me write the zeros before the dozen
So this is the price of 6 guavas minus 0.30 multiplied
at the real price
So I only take 30% of the real price
of the real price.
So we'll find her.
This will be equal to $ 12.60 here.
This will be equal to 12.60lv.
I just took 30% of the whole price
And now we're just making algebra.
We can imagine that there is a unit in front of x - you know,
x is the same as 1x.
So 1x minus 0.3x will be equal to 0.7x.
And togaway 0.7x, or we can say 0.70 if you like.
It is the same number
Point, or 0.7x is equal to 12.60.
And once you get used to these tasks, you can skip
right up to this step
where you say 70% of the total price =
the price of the reduced fruit
I removed 30%
These are 70% of the total price
You can move on to this step as you get used to it
with these tasks.
And now we have to find x.
Divide the two parts to 0.7 to get that x =
12.60 divided by 0.7.
You can use a calculator, but it's always better
to practice with the dozens
So let's do that
0.7 holds at 12.60.
let's multiply the two numbers by 10, which we do like
move the comma, the decimal to the right.
So 0.7 is going to 7.
Do not pay attention to this here
12.60 goes to 126, put the comma right here
The tenth right there
And now we are ready for the great division
This is now 7, not 0.7
7 fits at 12 once
1 in 7 is 7
12 - 7 = 5
Download below 6
7 ranks in 56 eight times
8 at 7 = 56
and we have nothing left to do
So 18, and there is nothing after the comma
In our case, we get 18
So x is equal to BGN 18.
Remember what was x? x was the total price of guavas
x was the full price of 6
x is the actual cost of 6 guava
Now, the question is, how much will it cost me 2 guavas
at full cost?
This is the price for 6
You should immediately remember how much it is
the actual price
Shares 18 to 6
Which is equal to 3
Ie. 3lv. for guavas
And they ask us if we want 2 guavas
And two guavas are 2 at 3 leva.
which is 6 BGN.
6lv.
You could say, hey
6 fetuses without a reduction would cost me 18 lv.
2 is one third of 6
And a third of 18 is 6
Let's repeat briefly what we did
We said we bought guavas for 12.60. .
Which is a 30% discount
Or you could say 70% of the real price
70% of the total price
Then we said that 30% - if we take x for the real price
on 6 guavas, you can tell the real price of 6 guavas minus
30% of the real price of 6 is equal to 12.60lv.
which is also like, 70% of the redeemed price is 12.60.
We divorced - and then we algered it algebraically
we divided the two sides to 0.7, and we got the x, the real price
of 6 guavas, which is 18, or 3 for guavas or 6lv. for two
I hope all of this has helped you.